foreign
welcome to another episode of Science
and Technology q a for kids and others
um
let's see
have a bunch of questions
saved up here
and let's take a look
okay we have a question here from Seth
could I discuss the importance and
relevance of chat GPT
uh and asking um
the thing things about its relationship
to wolfen Alpha and so on so first of
all what is chat GPT it's a
chat bot based on a language a machine
learning language model they made this
particular one is made by open Ai and it
is a lovely thing you ask it a question
you say something like um or you you ask
it say write me an essay about blah blah
blah you could take a prompt from a
typical you know college admissions
thing or a typical uh kind of high
school essay prompt you say write me an
essay based on this and it's rather
amazing because it can actually produce
a an essay that at least on the surface
seems completely sensible and uh is uh
is kind of well constructed has full
sentences it has a flow it has uh it
seems to often end with an in conclusion
comma how does it work well at a
simplest level it's trained from a large
Corpus of information a large collection
of information that probably includes a
decent fraction of the web pages that
are out there there are some number of
tens of billions of web pages out in the
world and uh you can just read them all
and that's what the system over a long
period of training that's been pretty
expensive in CPU and GPU intensive to do
has been able to do so let's zoom out a
little bit and just ask what's sort of
the basic idea at the simplest level
what this is doing is it's a language
model what does that mean it's something
which knows the probabilities for
different kinds of sequences of letters
that will occur in constructing a a
linguistically correct sentence for
example
so let's let's take some very simple
examples of that so let's say you're
writing English and you write a cue okay
there's a very high probability that
that's followed by you because in
English you know q u is the typical form
that occurs inside inside words if you
have th e it's a pretty good chance
that's the word the and it's going to be
followed by a space
so at the very simplest level you can
try and make this kind of a a a
statistical model a probabilistic model
for a language like English and you can
say the chances are this the sequence of
letters you know a th might be followed
by an e for example has a certain
probability it's much more likely that a
th is followed by an e than that a th is
followed by a j that's extremely
unlikely that's really not a possible
thing to have in correct English so you
start off at that very low level of just
saying what are the things that have a
probability a good probability to be
correct in English and how do you figure
that out well you look at a bunch of
actual English sentences and English
words and you say Okay given a th what
comes next there's a certain probability
for an e to come next a certain
probability for an a to come next
there's zero probability for a j to come
next and so on so given a uh election
let's say you have a million English
sentences you can get a pretty good
estimate of what letter will come after
what pair of letters let's say that's
the very simplest level is to just say
let's say the very simplest thing might
be okay the the very zero thing is what
letter is most common to occur
altogether so in English that would be
an e for example T would be next
so that's not taking account of any
context for letters that's just saying
if you were just writing down letters
one at a time independently you'd put
down more ease than you were booked that
put down Z's and q's and so on now let's
say you're looking at pairs of letters
then th is pretty common uh F Q is not
common at all doesn't occur at all so
you have different probabilities for
those pairs of letters and you start
building it up and saying what's what
things are likely to occur and in
particular if you say well I've already
got these letters already written down
given that those letters have already
been written down what's the likely
thing that's going to follow those
letters and so in order to figure that
out the more the more that you need to
the more kind of uh uh the kind of
further the the more letters you've
already put down and you say what's the
probability for the next letter if you
want to have something you've learned
from kind of examples the more letters
that you have in that context the more
examples you have to have to give you a
good chance of having seen an example
that's like the one that you're now
being presented with so very simplest
way that one can sort of statistically
construct English language for example
is this thing of just take take
sentences and grind them up and say
what's the most common trigram three
letters that come together and so on
okay that's the that's the sort of
zeroth level doing that you will produce
if you say to you can set up a sort of a
system and those have existed for 50
years 60 70 years now of uh just what
are the statistics of English and sort
of Babble out things that are have the
rights to statistics at the level of
individual letters or pairs of letters
or triples of letters or whatever and
the results will be terrible though they
won't really sound like plausible
English at all they'll certainly be no
sort of thread of a story that carries
between them and so on okay so then you
go to a slightly larger level and you
say well what can we how how can we
sort of learn uh sort of the larger
structure of English
well the idea of just saying you've got
these two letters there's a certain
probability of a letter that follows
them that's too simple a model too
simple an internal model to be able to
really learn how English works you know
in other words just because let's say
um you know the cat sat on the mat okay
cat sat that might be a pretty common
thing but you might say
um uh what would be a good example let's
say
um uh sat could uh maybe sat phone would
be a common kind of pair to come after
sat satellite phone
um so then you'd end up with cat sat
that's pretty common sat phone is pretty
common and then if that's all you knew
you'd end up with the sentence being
produced by saying cat sat phone which
is a pretty silly sentence
um but so the issue is to have a more
sophisticated model for how English is
constructed now one of the things that's
happened through neural Nets is one has
these kinds of ways of sort of flowing
information from one part of a part of
let's say a sentence to another in more
sophisticated ways than just saying what
follows what
so for example a pretty common kind of
thing these days okay so
let's see how do we start describing
this
um
so neural Nets
are kind of a
sort of a drastic idealization of how we
think neurons and brains work but for
these purposes a typical kind of neuron
that says I'm going to take I'm gonna
have a thing let's say it's an image
let's say it's an English sentence
whatever else I have a thing and I'm
going to kind of uh sample
10 different places in that thing and in
fact before I even do that sampling I
will have turned the thing into a
collection of numbers so for an image I
might turn it into numbers that come
from its red green blue values of each
pixel for an English sentence I'm out at
the beginning turn it into numbers by
just saying an a is one B is two Etc but
I can have more sophisticated encodings
of my input that have the result of just
turning it into a collection of numbers
okay so then what does the actual neural
net do what it's doing is it's taking
that array of numbers and it's sampling
different numbers out of that array and
it's saying okay well I've got this
combination of numbers now what it does
is it says I'm going to combine those
numbers and I'm going to say if this
number minus that number plus this
number minus 3 times that number and so
on is greater than zero then produce a
one otherwise produce a seven it's a
it's a collection of kind of little in a
sense math formulas that are being
applied given a collection of inputs
apply the math formula give an output
and you keep doing that you keep doing
it a billion times as and you do it in
lots of different sort of configurations
of sampling this piece and that piece
and so on and the thing is just doing
that you say well I'm sampling these
different pieces let's say you're a
sampling piece of an image I'm sampling
the left corner the right corner this
corner that the this combination of
things and this region of the image I'm
sampling this and that and the other
okay if you do that just saying you're
sampling all those things well well so
what you can't can't get much from that
the big idea is to learn
to to have something where you train the
system so what you're doing is you're
saying okay in a in a simple case you're
saying let's say you're trying to
recognize images you're trying to say
what's a cat what's a dog what you would
do is you would give it you know 10 000
examples of images of cats 10 000
examples of images of dogs
and then what you're trying to do is to
get it to set up all these little
mathematical functions that are that
it's applying to all these different
inputs and so on all these different
parts of the input and then it's
supplying results to the results of that
and so on it's making this whole Cascade
of things what you want to do is you
want to set it up so that all those
little math formulas inside are set up
to be the right formulas to best
discriminate cats from dogs and so the
big idea there is that you're looking at
you you run you have a version of what
you think this net with all its
functions and so on might do and and and
you do the you get the results from that
and you say those results are terrible
and then you say but if you were to sort
of poke them in this direction they'd
get better and then what you do is you
say that and you you have to say given
that they get better if you poke them in
that direction how do I have to change
all the parameters to those math
functions inside to get the results to
to be to be moved in the direction of
getting better and that's a big
adventure in essentially calculus
um essentially the way you think about
this is It's a
um
it's a it's a great application actually
multivariate calculus
um if that's something you've learned to
try to understand how does this changing
the output how do you change all these
sort of functions in the middle to to
make the output go in the direction you
want but anyway the end result is after
lots of training many many rounds of you
know just poke that you know you see how
the output has to move you see how that
what consequences that has for a little
functions inside you do that over and
over and over again
Millions trillions of times and then you
get a trained neural net where all those
functions are set up so that it's really
pretty good at discriminating a cat from
a dog now in that particular case one of
the problems will be if you just trained
it that way you've got cat images you've
got dog images and you say do that train
so in what language there's a function
classify and you literally just give it
a collection of you know cat images say
those are cats dog images they say
they're dogs you say
classify any image based on this
training data and it will go through and
grind through and it'll show you a
little little thing that shows you how
the loss function which is the the
chance of getting it wrong so to speak
how that's how that's going down and so
on and it's gradually going to learn
okay so one of the problems will be you
showed a picture of an elephant what's
it going to do all it knows is
everything's either a cat or a dog okay
so an elephant who knows what it'll say
an elephant is for example in that case
it doesn't know what it doesn't know
it's a separate and slightly more
complicated thing to to be able to train
it not only on what cats like what a
dog's like but also how close do you
have to be to a cat to be pretty sure
that it really is a cat as opposed to it
being something you don't know what it
is like an elephant
so
any case that's sort of the the general
approach to how do you train these
things but now one thing that happens
when you're dealing with something like
text
is that so for example image
identification you look at a picture of
a you know picture and you're picking
out does it have a cat or a dog in it
you're looking at text text has a flow
to it it goes you know there's the
beginning of the text and then there's
the next word and the next word and so
on there's a whole sort of time based
flow to text and so that requires a
slightly different kind of approach in
neural Nets than the thing I just
described by the way I should explain
that in dealing with images in neural
Nets one of the Innovations of a decade
or so ago was what I call convolutional
Neural Nets in which these all these
different functions that are sampling
things are doing that sampling based on
an array of pixels that's already a
two-dimensional array of pixels they're
not just saying we'll sample from
anywhere we choose they're saying we'll
sample locally nearby pixels in the
image which is how we know our visual
cortex works it's also very similar to
Cellular automata which is something
I've studied at Great length
um but you know so already it has sort
of to to know it's dealing with an image
it's using the fact that images are sort
of local in two Dimensions that is that
you know in an image there'll be an
object that's in this place in the image
and what happens at that place in the
image is all about that object and
something way in a different part of the
image is kind of separate from what's
happening with that object and so no one
likes to deal with images typically are
these convolutional neural Nets that
make use of the fact that there's the
sort of locality in in in the in the
sort of space of the image so to speak
okay so for text there's this kind of
flow one-dimensional flow of you know
one piece of text follows from another
and so on and so there are a variety of
techniques for dealing with that
transform and that's uh one common kind
of thing and uh there's this kind of
notion of attention layers and so on and
and one of the points there is to be
able to say given that you've got this
this input given that you've got this
thing that you're working on sort of
what part of it should you pay attention
to in other words one thing you can say
is well we've got this neural net and
it's just taking every part of the the
data that we have and grinding it up
with separate functions and so on but
one of the ideas of sort of attention is
that well actually you're only going to
pay attention to this one part that's
the part you're going to you're going to
you're kind of both saying you're going
to process it and you're going to say
what are you going to process what thing
you're going to pay attention to next
and and I think the the Transformer Nets
which are a popular modern technique one
of the things that you're learning is
sort of how to how to choose what to
look at next so to speak in addition to
saying what are you going to do to what
you are looking at you're also learning
the process of knowing what to look at
next
so these are some techniques that the
end result is you have a big Network and
you it has all these connections and the
question is if you feed it all these
examples can it learn from those
examples to be able to for example uh
well one thing you might be doing is is
like this example is a cat this one's a
dog or you might say just learn from
these examples of English and make me
things like those examples or more
particularly if you've learned really
well how to make examples of English if
you start off the beginning of the
sentence say how am I going to finish
this sentence well if you've learned
well enough it will know that this is a
possible end for the sentence it will
pick at random
um between its possibilities but it will
pick with probabilities which are such
that it will be make a plausible English
sentence to a plausible end to your
English sentence so the technology for
doing this is steadily been getting
better and better and the question of
kind of how Global does is the knowledge
of what you put next into your sentence
that's becoming more and more Global and
it's becoming more and more that instead
of it just being something where you say
what's the next word it's like what's
the sentence what's the next almost the
next paragraph I'm not sure how how
Global it really gets but then when you
say well what am I going to put in there
well if it's you know an octopus has
eight legs or something you know and
it's got It's going to be talking about
an octopus and it's going to say tell me
something interesting about an octopus
and it's going to have read the web and
it's going to have found that on the web
there are 10 000 places where there's a
sentence that says some version of an
octopus has eight legs hey they're not
legs tentacles whatever it is maybe it
says octopus has eight legs in which
case what the thing will learn is okay
an octopus has and then maybe it knows
it wants to go go somewhere about legs
and then it says well okay on the web
I've seen all these examples of an
octopus has eight legs so that's what
I'll fill in
um it's not you know it will the chance
of saying an octopus has 10 legs there
aren't examples of that on the web so
it's not going to say that so what it's
doing is it's making something which is
kind of a mashup of all the things that
it's seen on the web with all the right
sort of probabilities for what's going
to come next now what it learns is not
just what word is going to come next it
also learns the structure of sentences
and the structure of things so if you
give it you know if you ask it um
um I don't know if um
if all elephants are red and Bob is an
elephant you know what color is Bob it
can know that that kind of sentence
construction is something like a
syllogism and it will know that
structure because it's seen many other
things with that structure it's not just
that it's um uh
it's not that um uh it's not just about
elephants it has recognized the higher
level structure so to speak now when I
say it's recognized it's like can you
point to where inside that giant neural
net with billions of elements and so on
where it where it learned that no you
can't it's something that is it is a a
thing probably very much like our brains
work where it's all sort of mashed
together and the end result is that it
produces this this output
so what's what's rather impressive with
gpt3 in this chat GPT system I think
it's taken like a year or something to
train on on them uh on on really a big
collection of probably tens of billions
of web pages and so on and um uh it sort
of appears to know quite a lot
now
what's interesting is it will always
write plausible English it's English the
English it writes sounds great it sounds
great more than just at the level of
individual words it sounds great at the
level of sentences even paragraphs and
so on of course it might write complete
nonsense and it's kind of interesting to
play with it and and you know there are
things where slam dunk there's a that
statement is on the web somewhere and it
can pick up that statement it might
rephrase it a bit but it's basically
picking up a a true fact or whatever
from the web but then you know if you go
for example you can try I don't know
what's the what's the fifth digit of pi
okay we've got the right answer you say
what's the ten thousandth digit of pi
well maybe we'll get that one but if you
say that 12 514th digit of pi it will
confidently assert that that it's a a
three or something and it'll be wrong
but this what it'll say is a lovely
piece of very plausible impressively
plausible English text it just might
happen to be nonsense
and so
it's sort of interesting because this is
a thing where it's very human-like it's
it's PR it's providing a great kind of
humanization of things and it kind of
sounds right to us as humans of course
the the sort of the underlying sort of
computation and facts might not be right
and so it's kind of uh well let's talk
about another domain where there's also
been lots of progress recently which is
a visual image production
instead of saying let make me a
plausible English sentence you can say
make me a plausible uh picture so you
know I I was actually just playing with
this and uh the well this I was playing
with um a system called mid-journey
which is one of the one of the systems
for doing this and um it uh
uh and I say make a a wolf Dash Ram you
know a Wolfram animal combo in the style
of Escher
okay and It produced some very
interesting nice looking pictures which
are sort of using the Escher style
that's something even with a more from
language we have a image style transfer
image restyle which will take one image
and style it like a like another image
so you can say take this this plot that
I'm making and style it in the style of
Van Gogh's sunflowers picture and it
will take sort of the statistics of the
sunflowers picture and apply it to the
actual sort of raw data of the of the
graphics of the plot you're making
but so these systems that um do image
generation do a more elaborate version
of that now what's interesting is the
things they get right the things they
get wrong for example hands tend to be a
thing that's very hard to get right and
so you generate hands and oh gosh
actually that hand has eight fingers on
it because it sort of had learned this
kind of variation of of structure from
one finger to the next but it didn't
know how to count to five so to speak so
that's a typical kind of thing that
happens it's kind of looks right from a
distance particularly when you when you
go into the details it's like well it
couldn't didn't really understand what
was going on it's just getting something
statistically correct but the scale of
that statistics is large enough that
even at the level of a whole image it's
going to be something that is is
reasonable and correct so people have
now done this uh well for images that
was sort of in the last year or so it's
a thing that really got to a good place
um for text it's really just now the
last few weeks even getting to a really
good place it hasn't yet been done for
music it certainly will be done for
music
um and uh uh it's it's sort of if you
look at well in the very distant past
like 2005 we did a little experiment uh
turned into a thing called war from
tones that was a thing for generating
that's it's on the web you can you can
play with it oftentimes.com
um it's uh
a thing that uses cellular automata uses
simple programs uh where you pick the
program at random it generates a pattern
of behavior you take that pattern of
behavior you essentially use it as a
musical score and the way that system
works is it it generates lots of
potential musical scores at random and
then it has criteria to say oh that
seems like a classical music piece that
seems like a pop music piece and so on
and then it renders them with the
appropriate instruments and provides
them on the site so that's a place where
you're you're kind of starting from Pure
computational universe and you're kind
of uh sort of creatively surfacing
pieces of music it's what's interesting
about it to me is that you know people
use it for video games people use it for
various kinds of composing and so on
it's a thing where you can Mass
customize the results every time you
press the button you get a different
piece of music my original use case was
back in the day
um in 2005 I wanted to have a unique
cell phone ringtone for my cell phone it
was a short-lived issue but um uh that
was sort of we built this technology
just because I I thought it'd be
interesting to be able to do that and
just sort of press a button and get a
unique ringtone so to speak not a very
strong use case but um uh but fun anyway
but in any case that that so what what
we're doing there is very much raw from
the computational universe pluck out of
score what will be possible is to do
something that is much more like what
we're seeing with English and with
with text and with with images which is
make something which
kind of has ingested all the musical
works that are out there and it knows
kind of the statistics of what happens
in music and then you're driving it with
something kind of random but it's then
working itself out using the statistics
of music that exists and using all the
information about harmonies and so on
that are statistically encoded in you
know learning from the music that
already exists but anyway that something
hasn't yet quite happened
um and although still images are here
videos are again something hasn't quite
yet happened as a thing that you can
sort of automatically generate uh from
from and and what you're doing in a lot
of these cases is you give it a prompt
and then it generates based on that
prompt so the simple-minded version of
that is the English text where you say
uh you know complete the sentence
another version of that is with images
it's learned many kinds of descriptions
of images textures descriptions of
images along with images it can learn
that from the web by looking at the alt
tags of images and things like this
um but from that it means that you can
give it a prompt that says you know make
a picture of a a red elephant dancing on
a uh
I don't know dancing on a float or
something
um the uh
and it will know those terms from having
known the associations of alt tags with
images and then it will kind of start at
statistical mash up process of making
that elephant picture and so on
um so you can you give it a prompt that
is a set of English words or whatever
and it will then associate those with
images and then and put those images
together similarly in the case of of for
example chat GPT your your um uh you're
giving it a prompt and it's it's more or
less thinking it's sort of completing
from that prompt but it doesn't it isn't
just completing it's like that might be
something that had seen on the web where
there was a prompt and it said write an
essay about blah and then it sees what
comes as a result of that and then
that's the that's its sort of a piece of
training data for that
so one of the things that sort of the
the emerging issue is what we might call
Prompt engineering which is okay you get
a picture you know I got my my Escher
Ram wolves so to speak drawn but maybe I
I thought they were pretty cool actually
but um maybe I didn't quite like it and
I wanted it to be more ram-like unless
less wolf-like more ram-like let's say
how do I achieve that how do I change
the prompt and so maybe I can say
something like mostly Ram with a little
bit of wolf
and maybe that will cause it to kind of
you know sort of do something a bit
different because it's going to use some
other uh something else it's it's often
hard you know you're kind of almost
doing psychology on the neural net
saying well how did it figure out what
it was going to do and um that's uh
um
that's something we're not great at
doing that kind of psychology you're on
that psychology I think it's it's a it's
a it's an activity it's a profession
probably of kind of uh machine learning
psychologists so to speak uh AKA also
you know also very similar to a prompt
engineer you know what do you tell it to
do to get it do the right thing kind of
reminds one of of somebody who becomes a
you know horse Wrangler or something
like that what do you what do you you
know what do you do with the horse to
get it to do the thing you want it to do
this is the same kind of thing but now
we've got an AI and it's sort of a
wrangling process to get it do the right
thing or it's sort of a psychologist
process what was it thinking when it did
this okay what was it thinking now what
intervention can we give it so that it
will now do the thing we want it to do
so some of these systems have pretty
structured you know you can say oh take
get rid of the Symmetry constraint for
making the images or something like this
I'll others it's really just you're
using words to describe what's going on
and you really just have to sort of do
that prompt engineering so you know a
thing that I've been
building for the last four years or so
it's kind of a quite different approach
to kind of figuring stuff out and so on
in in the case of something like chat
GPT it's doing this kind of statistical
thing it's it's ingesting the web and
all of the sort of statistics of what
you find on the web and that's one thing
what what we've been doing that sort of
has a consumer face in more from alpha
um and an intelligent assistance that
use wolf malfur and things like this
um the uh
uh what that's doing is something rather
different what we've done over the last
I don't know 30 something years is
collect lots of knowledge about the
world in a very structured way and lots
of ways to compute things about the
world like how to compute what the
distance to such and such a planet is or
how to compute uh what the uh sort of
what the lift on some airfoil is that
this this or that thing all these things
there are ways that one can compute
these using sort of precise scientific
type methods
and they're also just facts about the
world which we can get you know the fact
that you know the color the the uh
calorie content of a such and such is
this and the density is this and the
volume will therefore be this and and so
on and so on and so on so
been trying to sort of learn lots about
the world not by virtue of just sort of
having an automated system do it
although we have lots of Automation in
in the process of doing this but try to
make kind of a structured representation
of the world and that goes along with
the computational language well from
language that I've been building for the
last world in its current form for the
last 36 years but in some form 43 years
and the goal of that is to have a
precise way to talk about the world
computationally
so to be able to say you know what's the
geo-distance between the entity that
represents this city The Entity that
represents that City the thing about
computational language is once you can
describe something in computational
language you have a very precise
description of it you have uh and and
from that precise description you can
then compute things and you can build up
this whole Tower of computation and
you're not worried that the whole thing
is sort of built on Sand because it's
built on the solid computational
language where everything has a precise
meaning so that's kind of a once you can
turn something into computational
language and we have the curated
knowledge to be able to uh to work out
what what you want from that or we have
the algorithms and models and so on to
be able to work that out that's great
now the next issue is well how do you
turn for example natural language a
natural language question into this
computational language and that's the
thing we built in modern Alpha starting
so 15 years ago or something now is
natural language understanding where the
target is the Wolfram language
computational language so we turn what's
the distance from New York to London
into essentially geo-distance of entity
uh you know City New York New York
United States blah blah blah
you know we're turning that natural
language sort of vague English and now
also Spanish and Japanese and other
languages
um we're turning those things into this
precise computational language from
which we can do computations okay so
that's that's kind of the the wolf and
Alpha end of the world war from language
end of the world kind of the opposite
end of the world from what uh you know a
chatbot system is something like chat
GPT or gpt3 is doing which is to do this
kind of learn the statistics of things
in the world we're instead saying we've
got a precise description of the world
where we really know what's actually
going on and we can compute things from
that and you could sort of look inside
and you can say what is the
computational language that well of NAFA
turned this natural language query into
and we get the we can we can sort of see
the see what's there and we as humans
can understand it and we can see what
happens and then we compute from that so
it's interesting question how do you put
these together because one of the things
that happens with with GPT 3 and so on
as I say it will it will confidently
write a wonderful essay the only problem
with the essay is it's nonsense and so
how do you help how do you make it not
be nonsense well what you could say is
well what if you know gpt3 could just
ask wolf now for a question at the
appropriate moment and get back
something which is actually known to be
true
well actually we're just figuring out
how to how to do some of this and it
looks as if by prompt engineering and so
on you can actually set things up so
that so that you you're sort of
generating a a Proto essay that includes
questions you feed those questions in
you get back the answers you use those
as assumptions and then you use that to
get a better version of the essay so
it's a way of kind of kind of
interweaving kind of the the
computational knowledge the the the sort
of computable facts
um and and computations in more from
alpha weaving it together with the kind
of the ability to sort of statistically
generate a plausible piece of English
text so that's sort of a Coming
Attraction potentially you know it's
interesting to think about given this
technology of being able to sort of
write the arbitrary piece of good
English so to speak what do you do with
that I mean the the most obvious thing
thing is you take I'm kind of wondering
I'm I'm wondering for myself I think
it's College admissions season right now
and there are lots of these prompts from
at least in the US you know colleges
will say you know tell us about a
a time when you experience personal
growth or some other such thing and um
I'm just I'm just wondering how many
people will feed in to gpt3 a a
paragraph about themselves together with
that prompt and have an essay generated
and how many of those sort of college
admissions essays this year will be gpt3
generated I'm I'm gonna guess it's going
to be a fraction of one percent but uh
won't be zero
um and I suppose the the the the much
more amusing essay would be something
where half of it was gpt3 generated and
then it says oh and that was generated
by an AI and then you can go and talk
about uh kind of what that means for the
world that that's possible but so that's
one use case but I think I think the
more interesting what not interesting
the more a use case that I think is
going to become pretty common I mean
there's a lot of places where people
write text and there are systems that
kind of harvest that text whether it's
product reviews on the web whether it's
some social media kinds of posts and
sadly most of those will turn into
nonsense because most of those will be
generated automatically in these kinds
of ways and they'll sound great they
just won't have anything particularly to
do with reality
I think another case that is going to be
pretty common is
another one that I'm not sure is is not
very good for the world but but um it's
a practical thing is when you're sending
out marketing emails you know you'll say
dear so and so I'd like to tell you
about this wonderful new you know pen
that you might use or something
um
and uh that has been something where
there's a mass mailing to you know 10
000 people or something of the same
letter or a you know back in when was it
probably 1980s it started to be really
common for one to get in the mail things
that said you know uh dear Stephen or
something as opposed to just being a
pure and then and then the rest of the
letter was was completely the same for
everybody but um but the the
introduction was customized you know the
greeting was customized that's been a
feature of mail merge programs since
since the 1980s but now what's going to
be possible is that that whole letter
can be sort of customized for you and uh
it's it's going to be interesting to see
because it's actually pretty hard to
tell uh you know that the text seems
pretty good and I you know I'm I'm um I
think um I wonder whether this happened
yet uh somebody inside our company was
saying they were going to take um
something to a uh an approvals meeting
for for material that we're producing
and we're going to bring some machine
generated material and see whether the
folks who are doing those approvals will
notice the difference so to speak
um even though the machine generated one
will probably be basically nicely
written but basically talking nonsense
confidently talking nonsense
um but uh
in any case that that's a um uh uh no I
mean when I say it's talking nonsense
the fact is it can still if you know if
if that fact is really widely available
on the web and it doesn't require sort
of computation and inferences and things
to get from here to there then it can
absolutely Trot out that result and you
know one thinks about kind of the analog
of web search and so on it's you know I
think post-wolf and Alpha search engine
started putting sometimes from us
sometimes not from us started putting um
uh some sort of direct results at the
top of their pages I remember founder of
uh let's say a very large search engine
uh when I had suggested this years ago
saying oh we don't want to do that
because if we put that direct results it
would cover up the ads
um and uh but you know it's a it's a
complicated ecosystem because obviously
such most the current major search
engines are funded not by the people who
use them but by the people who are
advertising on them I think there are
some new kind of startup search engines
that have a different business model
that involves you know you pay a
subscription and and you don't get fed
those kinds of ads but that you know
right now the model is It's ADS and uh
you know the ads can be even useful
because gosh you were searching for such
and such a you know a kind of thing and
you know the search engine produced some
results of of relevant pages but also
maybe the advertiser
um said well I I can give you a really
good pitch for why you should buy this
particular thing and you put it right on
the side and it's kind of competing with
the actual results in the search it's
kind of like if the results in the
search are too good you're never going
to look at the ads if the results are
just a little bit not so great then the
ads are really worthwhile and as you
start thinking about kind of uh some
kinds of results by the way I should
explain something which is in the case
of Wolfram Alpha for instance our goal
is to just kind of hit the nail on the
head get the right results we've got you
know a question you're asking we kind of
give an input interpretation of what we
think you're asking that's a very
structured thing and then we give the
answer and for us if we don't nail the
answer we failed
now if you're a search engine it's a
different story because you're going to
give 10 results let's say 10 pointers on
the first page 10 10 links on the first
page and if three of those links are
great it's a win the user is happy even
if one of those links is absolutely
Bonkers it's still a win so it's it's an
interesting case because the case where
it's a good case for kind of ai-ish
types of systems where you don't have to
get everything exactly right
the case where a wolf and Alpha and then
or from language you're kind of
expecting to build uh in this uh you
know one sort of uh one computational
result on part of another everyone has
to be actually right otherwise the whole
Tower is going to topple over and and so
it's a different it's sort of a
different set of requirements from the
case where there are use cases where you
can say look so long as we get it 80
right we're total winners
that's not good enough if you're trying
to do something like we're doing with
with wolf language where you're building
a computational language where you can
sort of build these whole towers of
functionality
but okay so so the question then comes
up sort of an interesting thing to think
about given the technology of chat GPT
for example what can one now enable in
the world and as I say I think this Mass
customized kind of marketing messages is
probably going to be one thing that we
will all see tons of you know it'll be
marketing messages it'll be political
messages it'll be all these kinds of
things where you can feed the system a
certain amount of information about the
the consumer and then feed it kind of
the the things that you want it to say
and it's going to make you a nice kind
of essay letter whatever else uh even
something in the right kind of form to
be a letter for example because it's
seen lots and lots of letters and so it
can follow sort of the statistics of
letters to produce something like that
you know I think that in a sense
probably the most useful version of that
will be that you'll you'll sort of use
the the intro letter
to be sort of the in to be something
that is maybe a bit mushy and maybe a
bit nonsense and then underneath you'll
have whatever it is you're actually
trying to communicate to somebody and I
think an analogous thing for the visual
version of this is you're writing some I
don't know a piece of some post of some
kind and you want a sort of a an anchor
image you want just an image to you know
a little icon or something something
where people can look at it and it's not
just a bunch of words on the page that's
a good case where you kind of just give
it you say generate me a picture of this
and it'll make a an interesting looking
picture you put that there it's kind of
an attractor for humans who are looking
at your page
um and it isn't you know then you have
the actual content of the page but sort
of what what the AI has done is to make
something which makes the humans pay
attention so to speak
um and and they can do that by by making
something which is kind of statistically
engaging to humans so to speak not
something that is um uh that necessarily
has to have all the quotes details right
but there are there are lots of kinds of
things I mean I think you know another
use case for uh
these kind of um uh text generation
language model type systems is oh I've
got a piece of text and I think it's
kind of clunkily worded can you give me
five rewordings of that text that will
be useful it's kind of a version like a
thesaurus one might use to say I just
can't think of the right word to put
here this is kind of a bigger version of
that
um so that that's another use case I
think um well there are a whole bunch of
other ones but but um uh that's but but
you know if you say oh is one going to
um
um uh is one going to use this
to um
uh you know to write a science paper for
example the answer is no it will write
nonsense it will write a note it will be
stylistically terrific I mean people
have been doing sort of little little
jokes for well I know about them for 40
something years I'm sure they've been
going on longer where it's kind of
randomly generated science papers you
send them into a science journal and
then there's some probability that the
science journal will say oh yeah it
looks great
you know because humans are not perfect
at telling what's something what sense
and what's nonsense and off it goes as a
as a contribution to the scientific
literature that will then be read by by
GPT and it will then become a fact that
is then regurgitated in Endless essays
and so on and I think the other thing
you know which one could certainly think
about is when when a lot of the the
content on the web is generated by a
language model system and then the
language model is learning from the
content on the web that's generated from
the language model system pretty soon
the AIS are taking over because that's
kind of a scenario where the the AI is
kind of learning from itself even if the
thing it's learning is this Tower that's
going off in a really weird Direction
because of some you know glitch and the
way the training worked or something
it's all learning you know it's learning
things that are very I don't know what
crazy in some way or another but that's
kind of a scenario for you know the it
becomes an AI civilization rather than
the human civilization because it's kind
of like ai's learning from AIS and so on
and getting their own internal value
system in a sense of oh yeah well I
learned that from another GPT and it
learned that from another one and pretty
soon it's it's got this kind of uh uh
this kind of internal way of of of
deciding what's important I mean we
humans in our civilization you know if
you say sort of abstractly what's
important in human civilization well you
know we have lots of cultural history
that tells us what we think you know
what we think we should consider
important but there isn't an absolute
version of that and you know so if you
if you sort of construct it separately
for the for the AIS you'll get some very
bizarre version of that
let's see okay various questions here
um
uh
Aaron is asking is this livestream
generate in real time by a Stephen Bott
uh you know I'd been saying that uh you
know I'm leaving enough sort of digital
you know
stuff digital exhaust so to speak in the
world that to make a bot at me is going
to get increasingly easy because there
must be you know there's hundreds and
hundreds of hours of video and this and
that and the other and uh you know in
time yes when we'll be able to make a
bot of me that will Yak on in a way that
locally at least will seem very much
like me in fact somebody sent me a bot
of me oh about what was that about six
months nine months ago now
um and uh it was interesting because it
was um
I think it was a gpt2 based bot
um it
uh somebody sent me a bot of somebody
else I think it was a John Von Neiman
bot
and it all seemed okay
and then they sent one of me and I tried
it and it's like this is terrible this
doesn't sound anything like me because I
think I know you know I've heard myself
Yak on for for years so to speak so I've
kind of got a sense of what I sound like
and I'm much more discriminating than I
would be about somebody where I've read
some of their works but I don't really
know it in in so much detail so but I I
suspect with the current round of
Technology but we'll be able to have a
more
um uh a more convincing bot of me
um you know I'd like to think that the
bigger sort of the things I try to do
that have sort of bigger intellectual
arcs aren't not really bot accessible
they're not accessible from sort of just
the statistics of of things things I've
said and so on
there's a comment here from a
J wouldn't an AI develop its own
language that we won't understand yes
absolutely and that has already happened
I mean in other words if you look inside
a machine Learning System inside a
neural net it's got all kinds of things
going on and you know you say is it a
cat or a dog in the image inside the
neural net there's a part of the neuron
that that's that's jumping up and down
and saying it's it's cat-like and but we
don't necessarily we don't understand
what it's talking about it's just some
weird combination of pixels that turn
out to be like the whiskers on a cat but
we wouldn't even know that so yes in a
sense it's like the thing that it's
jumping up and down about could be a
word that we have you know cat whisker
image like or something if we had it in
our in a human language but it's got a
version of that it's got a
representation of that it's got an
internal representation of that idea
which if it was externalized as a human
language we would give that a word but
it hasn't been externalized as human
language so it's an internal thing
within this neural net
now in a sense the the role of
computational language is to provide
this precise language that both
leverages the capability of computers to
compute things and to store knowledge
and so on and it's something that we
humans can understand that's been the
mission that I've been on for the last
many decades is building that
computational language kind of
constructing abstracting from the world
something which can be made into this
pure describable language and so on you
know I think I should mention one of the
things that's being done with these GPT
systems and so on is uh to write code so
writing I don't know code in Java or
JavaScript or python or whatever else
um
and I have the the it's interesting to
see that code because sometimes the code
is it's just like the English text it
looks sensible but it may or may not
actually be sensible or maybe total
nonsense it might even be syntactically
not quite correct it might have things
where the structure of that computer
language locally looks like this and it
correctly got that but globally it makes
no sense
but
what's sort of interesting is the place
that does best and there are other
things like I think the co-pilot system
on GitHub and things like this which are
kind of learning from code that's
already been written and saying
your code your code looks like this so
the probably you want to complete it
like this
um I have to say my view of that is any
system where that's really valuable is a
system that hasn't had very good
language design done because kind of my
goal in World language for example is
those lumps of computational work that
you repeatedly want to do I want to give
them words and those are functions and
you just use that function and those are
the building blocks that you build
things out of and the way you string
them together is always going to be
different and it's not going to be
something for which there is a ready
learning that you can make now that's
not absolutely true but that's the first
approximation I mean we've been doing a
bunch of experiments over the last
several years of building our code
assistance system which is a way of
telling you when you type in a piece of
code what are some well we already have
a lot of Auto suggestion capability of
what what kind of thing might you be
might be the thing that you you want to
type at this place that's but being able
to do that a bit more globally and say
this piece of code probably isn't right
this one is more likely to be right and
so on I have to say our experiments and
this is just sort of from the front
lines we've done a bunch of fancy
machine learning on that mostly it has
not been very useful we've got a bunch
of kind of rules that just say this
pattern does this and this thing those
have been really useful so that's just
an observation from the front lines
um again you know it's a question of
sometimes these machine learning systems
and that seems to have happened recently
with these text generation systems they
reach a threshold at which they become
humanly useful and when they're below
that threshold they're kind of like oh
that's just a toy
um it's uh I think you know one of the
cases that we've looked at quite
extensively is bracket matching where
you have something where you've got uh
you know you've got open paren you know
and then blah blah blah and then close
paren and somebody forgets the closed
brand
but often it's ambiguous there may be
multiple places where you can put that
close paren and they all give you things
that mean something different and the
question is where should you put that
close paren and we've tried to use
machine learning to figure that out and
it's been rather unsuccessful I'm sorry
to say despite quite putting quite a lot
of effort into it
um and that's uh I don't know why it's
been unsuccessful it's always a
difficult thing to know
um but it's sort of interesting that it
has been and that the rules-based
systems tend to be much better at that
um
let's see Parker's asking what's the
success rate of chat GPT generated code
I know For What from language we've done
a bunch of experiments and you know
I don't think the chance of getting a
complete piece of code that's correct is
really low the chance of getting a you
know part fragments that are interesting
is decent
um and uh
you know that that's um
uh right so spare parts is commenting
isn't there a feedback loop problem
where future language models will be
trained on AI generated text absolutely
absolutely that's a that's and that's
why you know that's the civilization of
the AIS developing itself because it's
kind of like you know that becomes their
reality so to speak their reality is a
reality in which a lot of the reality is
created by AIS
um and uh you know that that's that's
how us humans
um that's part of how us humans kind of
lose control of the situation is you
know it's it's it's much easier to
generate they'll be you know if we if if
you know let's say there's there's 20
billion human generated web pages out
there it would be easy to flood the web
with trillions of AI generated web pages
that have wonderful plausible text on
them that may be complete nonsense I
mean for example we had a decade ago now
we had a project to put a billion pages
on the web based on just facts from
Wolfram Alpha
um we ended up not doing it we started
doing it and we kind of got um uh it
didn't really interact very well with
typical search algorithms and things
like this so we stopped doing it and I
think there was a little bit of uh
intercompany uh
um rivalry that happened there and we
basically said you know we don't we
don't need to do this we're not going to
do it
um but that was a you know it was a case
where we could generate a billion
interesting useful correct pages
with this kind of text generation things
you can generate a trillion pages that
are
um kind of uh that have wonderful essays
on them
um that are kind of the uh the shadow
version of of whatever you know
Wikipedia or anything else a shadow
version of that that just has plausible
but utterly wrong
um I think we were just uh talking about
it earlier and
um the term fictional facts came up as a
as a description of um uh of what you
can get
um in these kinds of approaches and yes
that's uh it's it's a it's an
interesting problem because actually
it's sort of a fun thing because it's
like you know how does how does one
develop some weird
new accent some weird new kind of slang
version for let's say English well you
know you have everybody who lives in a
particular place they're talking to each
other and you know they start using
weird slang and so on and pretty soon
that sort of spins up and you have a
whole different language like I noticed
this between British English and
American English you know the the uh uh
since they weren't um you know since
they evolved a separate countries so to
speak for for quite a while now
um the uh uh you know there are things
that are American and you know they
build sort of in the American Direction
they build in the British Direction
um and uh that will happen with sort of
AIS that are trained on AI generated
text they'll eventually end up with AI
slang text that uh may or may not be be
you know the sad thing is that we humans
will probably be able to read it because
we will have seen so much AI generated
text that um uh that you know kind of
that's the that's the thing we'll be
used to
kind of reminds me of the thing that
happened oh 10 years ago or so now
um there was a whole maybe five years
only there was a whole story of how
essays for kids would start getting
graded automatically with AIS and so the
question is well if you're now trying to
game things and optimize everything it's
like how should you write an essay that
the AI will say is fantastic answer
increase the average length of words
start plopping in you know complicated
words but the AI doesn't know whether
the essay globally makes sense it has no
it's not turning it into computational
language for example it's just
statistically see what it what it makes
of that essay and so you can you know
it's rather easy to game it producing
essays which increasingly become
absolutely human incomprehensible and
human crazy
um but nevertheless it's like a plus
from the from the AI so to speak
um
let's see oh yeah that's Harry's
commenting that's it's a good idea at
the beginning of a chat you can prime
chat GPT to talk in uh various kinds of
slangs and so on oh have you actually
tried it yeah I can believe it I I
expect it will work
um and uh
you know one of the interesting use
cases is that you know language
translation has just in the last time
it's a year or two gotten really good
between lots of languages and um uh this
ability to really make sort of very sort
of smooth sounding you know I'm usually
interested in English as the output
language uh smooth sounding English is
really a big win there and a question
that um I don't know whether chat GPT
works with languages other than English
probably not right now
um but uh uh it's certainly true that um
uh you know this language translation
thing as one gets better language models
it becomes easier and easier to do good
language translation and by the way sort
of at the intermediate stage in language
translation you're kind of ingesting the
input language you're turning into some
internal state of the a of the neural
net and then you're going from that
internal state to generate the output
language
um so in that inside you have sort of an
inner language of the of the AI so to
speak that intermediate stage after
you've adjusted the input before you've
generated the output that's where your
sort of intermediate language is that no
human understands
um but it is kind of that is the
Intermediate Language of the AIS and um
the uh okay Aaron says chat GPT Works
across a bunch of languages quite well
okay I'm I'm uh I did not try it the um
it's uh presumably from the web it can
see lots and lots of different languages
um and I suppose it also probably works
decently as a translator
um I should try that
well let's see uh all sorts of other
comments about
um
uh
about this uh let me see
Paul is asking is it possible to
extrapolate what the future of neural
Nets will look like can they become
sophisticated as brains will they become
conscious and self-aware the whole
conscious and self-aware thing is is a
philosophical mess let's not get into
that one but the the question of whether
you'll be able to sort of talk to it
like you can talk to a person well the
answer is yes it depends right now you
know with this chat GPT you know
but some people I think that the
conversation it could have right now
would be an adequate conversation it's
not going to cut it for those of us who
are really kind of analytical you know
content-oriented folk
um I would say you know making small
talk it probably could do a pretty fine
job even right now as as being something
that would uh sort of pass for a human
in doing those kinds of things and there
are certain use cases uh I mean I I hate
to wonder what will happen if young kids
are like forget the babysitter we're
just gonna have a a chat bot
um AI talking to the kid I don't know
that's that's another way the AIS get to
take over our our species so to speak
um it's like
uh but I think you know that that's a um
um but in terms of
uh can one sort of build up the sort of
higher level kinds of things that brains
can do yeah progressively we'll be able
to do that and you know I think there
will be some things that are pretty uh
where you know that that's sort of the
last goal with these things that involve
these huge intellectual arcs of uh sort
of strategy of of uh and paradigms and
and sort of big thinking kinds of things
because those are the things that sort
of at the highest level of kind of
associating lots of different things and
and the hardware of brains and the
experiences we have in our lives and so
on are sort of good good fodder for that
kind of thing now you know ultimately
the hardware that we can make digitally
will be significantly better than the
hardware that we have in brains
um although we still don't know exactly
what parts of what brains do or really
the most important parts I mean do we
have to you know how much of the the
detail you know does it matter down to
the molecular level how neurons are
working or does it just matter what the
overall all architecture of this neuron
is connected to that neuron type of
thing but yes I think that's uh that's
what how that will play out now this
question of sort of the symbiosis uh
between us humans and uh and the AIS
that's another interesting question I
mean for me personally I've been kind of
a a computer dependent person for a long
time a lot of the kind of thinking that
I do and a lot of things I figure out I
figure out using Wolfram language you
know I figure out using computational
tools so to speak and I think a lot of
us are increasingly dependent on things
that computers can do for us so to speak
now you know there will be closer
connection between uh you know there's a
question about what point do you
delegate what to a machine like you know
time was when I used to have you know
lots of paper maps and I would try and
follow maps to figure out where to go
haven't done that in years just trust
the GPS and you know that's the thing
that sort of went went away and got
automated other kinds of things have
sort of gone away and gotten automated I
mean there was a time when I for example
would uh you know if I wanted to print
something I would like like had access
to you know printing printing stuff
where you actually could take pieces of
lead type and put them in a in a frame
and then start printing things obviously
that's been you know automated in a
zillion ways but but there's there's
lots of different things that get sort
of progressively automated and you know
a lot of things that wolf malpha does
for example the things people were sort
of doing by hand or looking them up in
encyclopedia or whatever else it was
before and now you don't do that anymore
um and uh so you know there'll be this
progression of things that are
automatable and I think that if you look
at you know what activities people do
that are not automatable I think there
are in terms of professions that people
do a lot of professions that were really
you know you're trying to you know
you're trying kind of get a human to do
something and the only way you're going
to be convincing is if you the human are
putting your commitment into it to get
them to to convince them that it's a
worthwhile thing to do and that's
probably true in teaching it's it's true
in in certain amounts and selling things
and so on it's true in in communicating
ideas things like this it probably there
are plenty of places where there sort of
has to be the the US humans at least for
now sort of still want there to be a
human commitment on the other end for us
to be convinced that oh yeah this is a
good idea type thing
um and uh the um
so you know and then there are things
where it's kind of like well what do you
want the objective to be you know AIS
can suggest things that are based on
sort of the statistics of what they've
seen before and based on you know if you
compute Things based on these are
outcomes that you might see but you know
when you ask and I've talked about this
at other other times here but but um you
know when you ask what's the what's the
big objective for the AIS they're like
uh I don't know we don't have a big
objective it's like you can ask humans
you know the the humans of the Earth the
eight billion humans of the earth what
is the big objective of humans of the
earth other than mostly okay we want to
stick around we don't want our species
to go extinct I say mostly because I'm
not even sure I don't know what fraction
of that eight billion humans are really
definitively convinced that that the the
universe will be better off if humans
were extinct but I think it's a pretty
small fraction but in any case you know
you say to the eight billion humans okay
what do you want to achieve and there
won't be one answer there'll be a
zillion different answers and you know
that's that's sort of the reason that
for AIS there's no kind of one answer to
what do they want to achieve that ends
up being something that comes from their
sort of imprinting from the humans who
created them and so on
uh
okay Harry is saying uh experiment where
chat gbt imagines being a Linux machine
and Converses in console that's cool I
was actually about to write something
about um what it's like to be a computer
I will have to try that it's a good
suggestion thank you
um
let's see
uh
ah Harry says chat GPT tends to not do
small talk very well I'm sure it will be
possible to do small talks I think the
problem is that the web doesn't contain
a lot of small talk I suspect I suspect
that's why it has trouble it probably
requires a different type of training or
some other kind of uh tweaking or some
some prompt engineering to get it to to
smallify what it's talking about
um
let's see
uh
HC is commenting that natural language
interpretation of both malfa is well
refined enough that uh they really want
to just crack open their voice assistant
and hack it to divert it to kind of a a
persistent personal notebook I think I
mean you know we've worked with a bunch
of the intelligent assistant folk I
think what's become clear with
intelligent assistance is there are sort
of restricted domains like send a text
message or whatever else where it works
really quite well
um in the kind of ask a general question
uh yes you can feed it to wolfen Alpha
otherwise it's sort of hopeless
um I think uh
you know one of the things that we've
been able to do in domains that we deal
with like more technical domains we
really have extremely high success rate
at understanding what the queries that
people type in mean which is kind of
neat and we're able to go from that
fuzzy natural language to the precise
computational language
uh
okay Russell was saying they wrote a
graph programming language in JavaScript
with chat GPT that fill the whole Lambda
Cube you see but the trouble is that one
will be more impressed with this if one
didn't know that there were lots of sort
of places on the web where things like
this are there
um and it is interesting that you know
if you sort of do the plagiarism test of
did did this piece of text come from
somewhere on the web the answer is
typically no because it's been rephrased
because it has a it has a model of
language which requires it sort of
operating at a level of abstraction away
from the actual words in the language so
that it is not going to generate the
exact same words that it saw on some
piece of input
um
let's see
spare parts commenting there's a recent
AI model that uses image diffusion to
produce music music via spectrograms
interesting okay have not seen it yet
these things are moving rapidly I have
not seen that
um
let's see
all right
um
okay Aaron is commenting that that
perhaps meta could train a language
model on its content from Facebook and
WhatsApp uh to be good at small talks
good idea uh yeah I I'm sure other
people have had that idea but it's a
good idea yes that's probably that's
what at least you get see what one thing
that's interesting to me is that
the type of way that people interact
with a computer is very different
depending on the expectation they have
for the particular system they're
interacting with for example search
engines different from Orphan Alpha
different from uh you know other kinds
of things where you are sort of typing a
keyword or something or doing something
like that each different kind of place
has a sort of very different uh set of
expectations for what you type in so I
suspect that
you know to get sort of you might post
this on Facebook type stuff then you can
learn well from Facebook if you want to
say you might say it verbally to
somebody it's probably going to be
different
um and uh you know subtly different but
in ways that you know again it's always
interesting what do we humans what are
we human sensitive to what do we humans
not really notice it's a you know famous
example that I think is you know right
on the edge of being solved is uh for
images and particularly videos
um having realistic human faces for
avatars in in um on a web or wherever
else
you know most of the avatars one sees
look really creepy we humans are really
pretty good at telling is that a
realistic face with all its muscles and
all those kinds of things moving in
realistic ways my impression is that
what's happened now is that kind of a
high-end movie can absolutely nail this
if you're prepared to spend enough money
and so on you can and and do enough
tweaking you can absolutely you know you
can get a realistic you know a decently
realistic face that really seems kind of
pretty successfully human it has not yet
trickled down I think to the level of
consumer Deployable stuff but it will
and and that will be another thing but
but it's interesting that's a place
where we humans are awfully sensitive to
whether it's right or not
um and I think the uh
uh uh it's it's just I'm always notice
for example here's one autocomplete
um you know sometimes we've worried a
lot about different kinds of
autocompletes and how do we make it
absolutely perfect turns out that uh
decent autocomplete is already very good
whereas there are other places where you
would say I mean there are things you
can add to are not a complete where you
know the human user will just roll their
eyes every time they see it because like
why did it put that in there that's just
stupid
um the uh I think that what um uh there
are things where we humans say you know
it's easier to get to good enough for us
humans and there are other domains where
it's really pretty hard to get to good
enough
um and I think the thing that's
happening now is kind of at the level of
essays and things like that it's easy to
get to good enough if you are looking
just at the sort of overall impression
of that it's making similarly with with
images and so on if you insist on sort
of true meaning at the level that
entails of the whole intellectual Arc of
a person's experience and so on we're
not there yet
uh there's a question here
um
the
um
from Aaron
would I get a neural implant at some
point in my life what could convince me
to do so
um
uh well I'm I'm I'm not not there yet
for sure
um I think
you know I think I've talked about that
a bit here before in fact I sort of
figured out a few things about that as I
was talking to you all
um you know right now we deal with
graphical user interfaces that are user
interfaces from computers to our eyes
if we imagine a a you know a neural
implant what we've got to do is have
interfaces to direct neural interfaces
what is that like well just like we
learn things about how things work in
our graphical user interface click here
click there and so on so also we would
learn things from our neural implants
about how to interact with our neural
implants but in order to give us a
chance we probably have to have good
um you know Nui neural user interface uh
design or something
um to uh to start with and you know what
a Nui should look like I don't have any
idea and we don't know enough about
Neuroscience I suspect to know how to
even start on a good new e
um so I think that's that's one thing
it's like you know can I connect in I I
you know it'd be cool to connect in you
know or from language Wolfram engine
into directly into one's brain with some
kind of Nui type thing where uh where
one's um
um where one's really uh uh where as
soon as I wonder about some oh I'm
thinking about this kind of uh rule for
sort of this computational rule what
consequences have I immediately
know what that is it's kind of like I
suspect the way it would feel is the
same way that it feels as you retrieve a
memory you know do I remember this thing
oh I think I think I think for a little
bit and boom it pops into your mind my
guess is that that's sort of what it
would feel like if you had a you know a
Nui thing connected into your brain
um is is you'd you'd kind of be like Oh
I'm thinking about this and and then you
know it's running the processing and
then up it pops into your mind the
answer is 42 or whatever
um and uh I think that's a um uh now the
other thing that would happen there is
the ability to presumably store memories
much more accurately and more completely
that we can currently store memories and
that will have both good features and
bad features I don't know what it would
be like to have a a you know a perfect
memory that does not kind of uh smooth
out the edges so to speak over time I'm
not sure I'm not sure what that would be
like I mean sometimes one one is you
know in some high stress situation or
something one will have a much more
precise memory of what happened just at
that moment and that can cause all kinds
of all kinds of problems and you know
it's it's kind of like the if you have
this perfect memory you'll get you know
post-traumatic stress or something or
something like that from all these
different memories that you have
crowding in I don't know those are
things that could happen
um I think it's you know it's it's
complicated to to foresee what will
happen in that situation but I think the
the two things are probably the most
interesting one is computational
computational knowledge capabilities the
other is enhanced memory
um uh uh are two things but but in a
sense the question is how much better is
it to have that directly in your brain
versus going through your fingers and
your eyes
um I'm not sure
um I think one can get sort of a
quantitative sense of that you know our
human reaction times uh are about uh one
third of a second or something like that
but between you know you see a light
flash you press a button things like
that we know that in our brains we're
already starting to see activity a tenth
of a second after the light flashes so
in a sense we've got you know maybe it's
a factor of three more efficient to be
directly connected inside as compared to
going you know out to our brains and our
computers and our fingers and our our
keyboards and our displays and things
like this and maybe that factor is
underestimated and maybe it's more like
a factor of 10 or something and then the
question is what do you get for that
factor of 10 increase in in uh in kind
of recollection speed and things like
this uh sort of an interesting question
because it's kind of like the the
comparison between oh I'll just look it
up on a computer versus let me remember
that you know it is somewhat more
efficient to be able to remember it
whereas it else is it more efficient
well one big thing about remembering
things at least for me I suppose is that
when I remember stuff I can readily kind
of pull together these three or four
different things I remembered and
connect them in my mind so to speak in a
way that is very different from if I
just separately got those three or four
things and then I separately have to
have the action of putting them together
I don't completely know the extent to
which sort of in in one's mind the
things get pre-connected so to speak
before you've exposed everyone and then
can sort of separately make connections
um
let's see
uh Harry is saying the first thing I
really want is a simple brain keyboard
you know when I was when I was much
younger
um a kid actually I you know I I knew
about sort of brain waves and things
like that and I one of the things I
always thought was one day I'll be able
to type with um uh
um
you know just by just by thinking about
things I have to say maybe part of the
reason for that was when I was
originally typing in the 1960s probably
mid to late 1960s and early 1970s was
typing on a typewriter as it happens I
just happened to uh run across again the
typewriter that I used back
certainly by 1971-ish type time frame
and I was typing on it and I actually
was amazed that the ribbon and the
typewriter still works after not having
been used in 50 years it's kind of cool
but anyway the thing that I learned is
oh my gosh it is so much more difficult
to type on a typewriter this is a
regular mechanical typewriter and a
computer keyboard it's like you have to
move that key you know an inch down to
get it to to to register and so on and
it's like I'm sure when I was typing on
a typewriter that the the appeal of
typing by thought was much higher than
it would probably be today
but I always thought that you know one
of the things you know I thought you
know you put a uh an electrode array on
you know if you put it externally the
easiest thing to do you're putting it
near the motor strip and the Brain which
is somewhere on the top of your head and
I always thought oh if one's hair falls
out and and you know that's kind of a
bad thing it's it's uh you know uh worse
sun protection and other things and and
uh makes one look more like a clown type
thing but um uh you know the the
compensation is at least it'll be easier
to attach you know the neural connection
type thing but it turns out it doesn't
really make much difference and even now
50 years later or more there really
aren't type by thought type techniques
that that exist now of course it it is
made more difficult by the fact that the
the detailed kind of neural uh signals
that come from the brain are very much
diffused by ones by one skull and the
scalp and so on but you know one of the
features of of technology and electronic
technology in particular is that every
problem that ends up being oh we can't
quite pull out the signal the signal is
too small there's too much noise there's
too much background those problems
always seem to get solved so I have to
believe that there's enough you know
there is there is a signal from the
neurons that that uh you know move this
Finger Versus that finger and so on
there is a signal and with good signal
processing one surely we'll be able to
pull it out without having to stick
something inside one's brain so to speak
to be able to do that that would be my
impression now and the result should be
one should be able to type maybe three
times faster I doubt one will be able to
type more faster than that
um I think it's also the case there's a
trade-off because in the um uh you know
there's a pre-motor strip in the brain
that where things start to sort of you
you have the intent of making a motion
for example but you can still censor
that motion
um in in other parts of the brain if you
pick things up from that pre-motor area
everything you think about doing it's
going to actually happen in the in the
world and you know I have to say I can
imagine many cases where it's like well
I was thinking about doing that but that
would have been a really bad idea and
you know I at the last minute I kind of
pulled back because I realized oh gosh
that's a you know that's something
that's really hot or something like this
um and so you know you kind of lose that
if you're going directly from the from
the pre-motor area
all right maybe one other
[Music]
um
oh boy there's a comment from gyro
question from gyro what are your
thoughts on AI connecting to blockchains
they could theoretically become
independent from humans yeah well
got a couple of comments actually in in
um a few years ago as an April 1st you
know April Fool's type thing I wrote a
piece about
um uh I forget the order of the words
Quantum neural blockchain AI maybe those
words were in a different order
and the fun thing was that even though
my prompt so to speak and maybe I should
feed that to chat GPT and see whether it
can produce an essay like my assay
probably could
um the uh although I I'd like to think
my essay was had more thematic sense to
it
um it uh the thing that was surprising
was given that prompt they were actually
very interesting interplays between all
of those different areas
um of uh
um it's uh yeah I called it buzzword
convergence making sense of quantum
neural blockchain AI okay I I don't know
if I had the words in the right order
before
um but uh
it's sort of interesting you know I was
realizing that Quantum measurement is
very similar to the consensus process
that happens in blockchain which is also
similar to the attractors that happen in
neural Nets
etc etc etc there's it's very
interesting that there are sort of these
common arcs across all these different
areas but um that that aside this
question of sort of the autonomous
uh bot in the world that's just making a
living for itself yes that's an
interesting thing that was a company
that uh I was an advisor for a number of
years ago which which was really trying
to do that and I was really sad that
they didn't they didn't make it
um they were trying to put bots on
social media platforms where the Bots
would like be friends with people and
tell jokes and things like this and and
maybe they'd have I think it was before
patreon but they might have patreon
accounts and it's like contribute to me
I'm I'm cool type thing and I'm going to
tell you some good jokes and I'm going
to provide you you know interesting
videos and maybe nowadays it would be
I'm going to generate some videos custom
for you and yes I I can completely
imagine that you could have something
which is just sort of an autonomous bot
that is uh sort of the interesting case
would be can it fund its own computer
Time by having people contribute to it
and I'm sure the answer is yes and
blockchain is certainly a helpful
enabling technology although you know
maybe it's challenging for the bot to
open a bank account it's much less
challenging for it to have an address on
a blockchain
um and if what it's doing if there was a
place I don't know whether there is at
this point a place where you can sort of
Buy computer time for for cryptocurrency
there must be such a place
um and I suppose you know the the
inverse of your your spending computer
time to mine you know proof of work
cryptocurrencies and so on that's
certainly a thing whether the other way
around is a thing I'm not sure but I'm
sure somebody has such a service and
then you can imagine a bot that is sort
of out there you know telling jokes
entertaining people people are giving it
you know that um they're putting the um
uh
um
uh you know that that their um
um
you know contributing they're putting it
like in the you know like in the music
case where people are like uh you know
uh Street musicians or something you're
you're putting the same kind of thing
for the bot that's uh that's
entertaining you on a piece of social
media you're giving it uh payment in
cryptocurrency and it's going off and
paying for its own uh for its own AI
Ness so to speak that way yes that would
be a fun thing
um actually I did wonder uh years ago
now
um and that's in that situation so you
can yes you can imagine a disconnected
bot I suppose that sort of floats off
into the world maybe it evolves uh bot
to bot as it as it um figures out how to
make itself better and it eventually
becomes you know maybe it that's the
first that's the question what's the
first millionaire
um kind of a completely autonomous bot
that's just making a living by
entertaining humans so to speak now of
course then it gets even more wild when
the bot is entertaining other Bots that
are giving it cryptocurrency and maybe
the Bots make enough uh you know
cryptocurrency by telling jokes that
they can mine more cryptocurrency and uh
uh and these kinds of things so it gets
it gets kind of wild and you really
start imagining kind of a a society of
the AIS now an interesting question in
the way that the human world is set up
today is what is the legal status of
such a bot so this bot is fending for
itself it's paying for its own computer
time it's uh it's made accounts actually
one of the issues that this company had
a number of years ago was that the
social media platforms were at that time
sort of saying you've got to be a human
to have an account here I think that's a
that's a challenging question whether
that should be the case is the case how
well enforced how enforceable is that uh
Etc et cetera et cetera and you know
proof of being human is is certainly
going to be uh you know it's that's a
thing we we all get is uh we've got you
know for now we've got sort of proof of
Being Human although it becomes more and
more difficult to to make an automated
proof of Being Human so to speak
um the uh you know to automate the check
or is it a human so to speak
um and there are all kinds of of things
where you know it's kind of like a you
get up a camera and it says you know
turn your to look left look right and so
on and you're kind of you know can you
respond to these things now eventually
there'll be an avatar that you can make
that will be able to do that Etc but I
it's kind of a a um uh sort of a
question I was I was curious about is
when you have this bot that is funding
for itself in the world
um what is its status you know like if
the bot starts being outrageous in this
way or that way it's like okay bot uh
you know who's responsible for you who
gets to take you down
and you know can you get into a
situation where where that's no longer
where that hasn't what that's not clear
it doesn't have an owner most things in
the world you know in the in the state
of the law so to speak most things have
owners not everything you know birds
flying around typically don't have
owners unless they're in England where I
think you know the Monarch owns all
swans and things like that
um but uh you know most places there are
things that don't have owners
um and uh and so the question is you
know can you have a thing in the AI
world that doesn't have an owner and you
can imagine very bizarre kinds of
situations like if you have a company uh
you could have a company and the company
a is owned by Company B and then you uh
you know you have paperwork that says
Company B owns company a so you've got a
loop of the company you know one company
owns the other which owns the other and
there's no external owner to the company
um now you know can you set up such a
Luca I'm pretty sure you can set up such
a loop what
um
you know right now such a loop is
absolutely pointless like why would you
do that
um but as you start saying you know the
bot has this thing it's an autonomous
thing and it's autonomous in in being
sort of completely separated from it's
like nobody's responsible for it because
it it it owns something that owns itself
so to speak and it has uh so that that
becomes a an interesting question and
you're kind of thrust into a different
level of AI ethics let's say you have a
bot and the bot has built up this huge
uh you know complex neural networks
learned all these things and it's it's
wonderful and people really like it and
it's able to tell great jokes and all
that kind of thing and then somebody
says you know let's this bot told a
terrible joke here we gotta shut it down
okay and the bot has no owner
what is the ethical status of shutting
down that bot what how should one decide
whether that bot should be shut down is
it a and is there an any obligation to
keep the bot alive so to speak or can
one can we humans just say oh no but
that bot did something bad you know
press the delete button and it's gone uh
you know at what point does it get to
the point where it has enough
uh in it and of itself that it should
have a kind of a a sense of self for
purposes for our purposes of sort of our
ethics I mean I think I think one would
one could ask the question you know if
the whole web was you know if let's say
there are things well we can think of
various hypotheticals like this it's
kind of fun to uh to see the um
um
uh
Harry is commenting but the AGI of the
future will be a comedian heavily active
in in advertising yeah well you know
this is the thing to us humans pull that
upon ourselves
um I mean this is that this is the
problem and this is the thing that one
comments on you know with with people
saying oh you know there's lots of
shocking things in social media and
there are lots of algorithms that are
making us look at more and more shocking
stuff
um and you know part of the point is uh
the the fact is I think it's true I'm
not absolutely certain it's true because
there's a lot of kind of complex sort of
socio-political factors mixed in with
commercial factors mixed in with
technology factors so it's a little
harder to entangle
um the uh but um you know it appears to
be the case that we humans are more
engaged by the outrageous than not and
therefore if you're an AI whose goal is
to increase human engagement you're just
going to do more and more outrageous
things
um and uh uh so so that's a you know
this is the problem that in a sense with
AI we're reflecting back ourselves but
with some degree of amplification and
it's a potentially amplification and so
you know what the most successful bot
autonomous bot you know going around
social media is like is going to be some
reflection of what we humans want at
least for the for initially because
initially we're the ones who have the
purse strings we're the ones who are
going to pay the bot initially until you
have a full Society of bots where
they're paying each other so to speak
but initially the kind of the um the
sort of the the chain of value has got
to come from us
um
okay a comment from haraz here uh
ownership might even be an ethereal
concept challenged by AI
yeah it's an interesting thing I mean
what does it mean
I mean look we're seeing a bunch of
versions of that issue right now for
example uh you know
these image generation systems are
ingesting lots of pieces of art made by
lots of humans and lots of humans own
that art and own the copyright to that
art and so on and then the system is is
you know pulling all of that in and
mashing it all together and then
producing a picture and there's a
question of sort of does the chain of
ownership break when when the thing has
sort of mashed it together with enough
other things and I think the answer has
to be pretty much yes because in a sense
that AI is operating like a human I mean
when you put something up on the web you
intend it to be read uh presumably and
uh that's something that you know we
humans can do it and also the AIS can do
it and it doesn't seem plausible that
one's going to be able to say let's
Trace through this trace of of
provenance of this particular set of
cluster pixels here is the heart of this
image and it's going to be traced
through and it shows up here that
doesn't seem like it's it's going to be
plausible and if it is is if there's a
system that just does that kind of
copying of a piece of image well maybe
that'll be what what it is today but in
three months it won't do it like that
anymore so I think that that's a uh um
that's kind of a uh what one version of
this thing about about ownership I think
also that um yeah there are a lot of
interesting questions about Will
you know owning one's AI I mean there
are things that one can you know when
does it come to a point where it's
thought to be sort of morally shocking
to own one's Ai and not to let one say I
have its freedom so to speak to go out
and uh and go around social media on its
own you know how why should you have the
right to control your AI at what point
does it get to be the case that you no
longer feel good about doing that and
and part of it you know in in
realistically us humans you know when it
comes to ethics we're the ones that are
sort of setting the ethics
um we don't uh you know perhaps you know
the whales or the Dolphins have an
Ethics too we don't know what it is and
we can only project kind of our ethics
onto other things that's the only kind
of source of Ethics that we have so
there isn't going to be sort of an
absolute this is the right thing to do
with AI it'll be well we human have to
kind of you know we have to develop
something that says this is how we
should think about AI ethically but I
think that's sort of an interesting
issue at what point does your AI get
well okay so there are many things that
can happen I mean for example your
personal pet AI might have mixed itself
so much with stuff that it learned from
other people does it is it is it
still your AI so let's say you take your
AI to school
and your AI is learning from your you
know from your teachers and so on okay
so here's a here's an interesting a
issue so the AI goes to college and
you as a human you go to college it's
really expensive in many cases you know
you're you're paying lots of money to
get educated in college but actually
you're coming with your AI it's like a
parrot it's in your shoulder except it's
an AI instead and your AI is listening
to all those lectures it's getting it's
getting all this value it's it's
ingesting it all it's learning from all
these things that you're learning from
at what point should the college say hey
wait a minute we're teaching two
entities not just one here you know we
we want to sort of uh we want college
you know we want tuition for the AI you
know when does that happen and you could
say well the the that's kind of a silly
scenario but if you you know if you
think about you know now you've got the
whole classroom it's like oh I didn't go
into class I just sent my AI to class
instead and the whole class is is with
AIS and and let's say you have an AI
That's that's well this is then the
question is if it's your AI That's just
yours then it just becomes well it's
like a notebook that you take notes in
but if it becomes something that's more
autonomous where that AI can you know
where it's your personal Ai and only you
will get benefit from it then it's
something where it would not be
unreasonable it would not be reasonable
to say oh you need separate tuition to
teach the AI but as soon as you have an
AI that can have an independent
existence and can for example go out on
the on the on the web and start making a
living for itself then then I think the
question becomes more complicated that's
that's what I not thought of before I'm
sure there are other ones of these
that's an interesting question what's
the um uh what the notion of um
um
I mean I suppose the the notion of
ownership
in a world of uh of of virtual things is
again more complicated and that's an
interesting topic maybe we can talk
about it another time uh okay this is
Aaron commenting but AI students
learning from AI professors yeah right
well right and that's where the AI
Society starts taking off because it's
kind of like um uh that you know and
then uh you know one has this image of
the um uh
okay you know we've automated everything
the AIS are doing everything we just we
humans just say okay great we can you
know kick back and and um uh and and
just you know
have fun well the problem is again in
the in the in our sort of the evolution
of us humans I think our species is not
particularly built to kind of do nothing
and just quotes do nothing and let the
AIS do everything what would you do what
would you do if you could do nothing
um and I know for myself I have an awful
lot of things that I want to do if I had
nothing that I needed to do so to speak
and but those things are probably not um
uh well and those things uh so so this
question of of what uh you know what do
the humans do when they can do nothing
or do anything so to speak is is an
interesting Challenge and I I suppose
it's uh you know you have um in a lot of
kind of uh people people talk about this
as sort of what's the what's the
situation when you're free of all kind
of um uh all constraints and and you
know in in religion they're sort of in
the afterlife you're you're kind of
you're hanging out and you're you're
doing the things that you sort of always
wanted to do but you had this nasty ugly
actual sort of existence in the world to
deal with what would you do if you
didn't have that what could what would
you do and and how would you sort of
spend your time and that's a um uh
that's sort of an interesting question
and it's an interesting question that
has to do with sort of the evolution of
human purposes and you know that I've
talked about this a bunch of times
before I've kind of you know the things
we do today that seem meaningful to us
today would probably not have seemed
meaningful to people 500 years ago or a
thousand years ago or whatever they're
things that get their meaning from the
experience that we have in the moment so
to speak and no doubt many of the things
that one could imagine sort of for the
future humans where it's kind of AI is
doing everything for them the things
that will emerge then might seem deeply
meaningful to those humans even though
to us today it's like oh there's a bunch
of people playing bad video games of
Eternity type thing and that might seem
horrible and pointless to us today but
it might develop to the for the internal
perception of the Observer of the future
so to speak
um it might seem completely meaningful
and and purposeful
um anyway oh boy we've we've uh that's a
that's a funny uh place to end here but
um I think we've we've degenerated into
um uh into talking about the kind of
philosophy of the distant future so to
speak
um but uh well it was fun to chat about
these things and um uh maybe we should
feed this um
the transcript of all of this to chat
beat GPT and see what it has to say
about it
um and uh see whether it can continue
and say more interesting things that
I've been able to say
but anyway
um uh we should wrap up here and uh
thanks for joining me and um uh happy
holidays and I'm not quite sure what our
schedule is but um I'll be back um
uh soon uh for uh another one of these
and um uh look forward to that anyway
for now happy Holidays happy New Year if
we don't have something before the end
of the year
um and uh
see you all another time bye for now